in a very basic sense if you've got a
general intelligence which therefore has
preferences overworld states and takes
actions in the world to change the world
we have to make sure that its
preferences are aligned with ours then
it wants what we want because otherwise
it's going to try and do things that we
don't want it to do that's that's the
basic idea sci fi comes to the fore but
we're talking things like terminator
matrix the machines take over the world
I for one salute our new robot overlords
it makes it difficult to think about the
problem right when things happen in
fiction it's generally what would make a
better story rather than what would
actually happen and I think a realistic
AI takes over the world type story might
not be any fun to read so on the one
side this stuff is difficult to think
about because of fiction because we've
all been exposed to something similar to
these ideas before the other side that
makes this difficult to think about is
anthropomorphism because we are talking
about general intelligence so we're
going to compare it to the examples of
general intelligence that we have which
is human minds and human minds and
artificial general intelligence --is
need not be anything alike in the same
way that a plane is not similar to a
bird a supersonic fighter jet is a
threat to you in a way that no birdie is
it's not a useful comparison to make in
fact but when you say oh it's a thing it
has wings and it flies and people who
don't know anything about planes
immediately go to birds presumably a
machine could be much more selfish than
we can ever imagine
absolutely the space of minds in general
is vast I like this because we've
already talked about spaces so I can do
this if you take a space of all possible
Minds it's huge and then it's somewhere
within that you have the space of all
minds that biological evolution can
produce and that's also huge somewhere
within that you have the space of actual
minds that exist which is much smaller
but still huge within that you've got
human minds right and there they're a
tiny there they're a minuscule dot on a
miniscule dot on a miniscule dot of the
actual possibilities for intelligence
that exists and a general intelligence
that we create is from a completely
different part of the space and
it's extremely tempting to
anthropomorphize more so even than in
other context because it's a thing
that's demonstrably intelligent that
makes plans that takes actions in the
real world but it need not think
anything like us and it's a mistake to
think of it as basically a person
because it isn't one so there's actually
a really good example that we can use
it's sort of a thought experiment this
is an on a machine that could
practically speaking be built this is an
example of artificial general
intelligence which is specified in
overview and it gives you something to
think about when you're thinking about
artificial general intelligence --is
that makes it distinct from a sort of
anthropomorphised human type
intelligence so the story is there's a
stamp collector who is also an AI
programmer and he decides he would like
to collect a lot more stamps so he's
going to write an AI to do this for him
so he builds a machine he has some
startling insight into general
intelligence and he builds this machine
which is connected to the Internet right
so the rules for this system are pretty
straightforward first thing it's
connected to the internet and it will
send and receive data for one year so
he's given himself a one year time
window within which to collect stamps
the second thing is it has an internal
model of reality or of the universe this
is the thing that's a bit magic we don't
really know how to build an accurate
model of reality the point is this
allows it to make accurate predictions
about what will happen if it does
different things the third thing is for
every possible sequence of packets it
could send it uses its model to predict
how many stamps it ends up with at the
end of that and then the fourth thing is
it outputs as it's actual data to the
Internet
whichever output it has predicted will
produce the most stamps you can see here
that this has all the properties of a
general intelligence it has an internal
model of reality it has a utility
function or an evaluation function which
is the numbers
and the optimization is extremely simple
and like so much in computer science
that the simple things to specify are
the hard things to compute it looks at
every possible output of data in other
words every every point in that space
and it picks out the highest one so this
is the kind of magic intelligence that
takes the entire space at once finds the
highest point and says that one which
means it's an extremely powerful
intelligence right it is you could say
it's extremely intelligent the question
is how does this machine behave well we
can look at certain possible sequences
of outputs and see how they fare in its
evaluation criteria first off the vast
majority of output sequences are
complete junk right it's spewing random
data onto the network
nothing happens of any consequence no
stamps get collected those are all rated
zero but suppose one of the possible
sequences sends a request to a server
let's say eBay that results in a bid on
some stamps right when that happens
there's a thing of twenty stamps so that
output is rated twenty this is the kind
of thing that the stamp collector
machines creator was expecting to happen
but so then that's good twenty stamps
suppose it could do that lots of times
it can send out bids for example two
thirty different stamp collectors on
eBay and buy 30 sets of different stamps
and that's even better right that'll be
rated even higher but the thing is that
particularly highly rated options in
this search space are probably things
that the stamp collecting devices
created did not think of and did not
anticipate so for example when he made
it he will have presumably given it his
credit card details or something so they
could engage in these bids but
ultimately it's searching every possible
sequence of outputs it needn't use his
credit card it needn't use money at all
there's a huge variety of things that it
could do here so it might send out an
enormous number of emails to all the
stamp collectors of the world and
convince them through persuasive
argument that he is
opening a museum and wants to exhibit
their stamps it may build a fake website
for that whatever is necessary it can
predict the world right it has an
internal model of reality that internal
model of reality can includes the people
right in the same way that it's modeling
people to understand that if it bids on
this offer then a human being will mail
the stamps to them they understand that
this email might get more people to send
stamps for example that's something but
then what exactly is a stamp how is this
defined what counts as a stamp if it's
already written the sequence of outputs
that collect all of the stamps in the
world you'd think you're done right you
built this machine suddenly it's
collected all the stamps in the world no
there could be more stamps within a year
we've got time to print more stamps so
maybe it hijacks the world's stamp
printing factories and puts them into
overdrive producing stamps as many as
you possibly can in that time or perhaps
it writes a virus and it hijacks all the
computers in the world to get all of the
printers in the world to do nothing but
print stamps that's even better right
the highest-rated outcomes for this
machine are not good for people there
comes a point when the stamp collecting
device is thinking okay what a stamps
made of they're made of paper paper is
made of carbon hydrogen and oxygen I'm
going to need all of that that I can get
to make stamps and it's going to notice
that people are made of carbon hydrogen
and oxygen right there comes a point
where the stamp collecting device
becomes extremely dangerous and that
point is as soon as you switch it on
so this is just a thought experiment
example where we take a sort of
maximally powerful intelligence and see
how it behaves so that we can think
about how powerful intelligences behave
and most importantly how they are not
like people